c'est ce que c'est ça à quoi ça sert
pour s'attacher les cheveux vous est ce
que c'est ça c'est du bruel
je suis designer et ja voir les jeunes
dans les eaux claires le potentiel d'une
deuxième vie je leur donnais un avocat
nouveau visage que vous vous présentez
ce processus créatif
à travers cette élite alliés gérant
contraire il ya quelques temps était
tristement abandonner une bretelle
d'autoroute
je me suis renseigné elle a été utilisée
pendant 50 ans père du trajet entre reed
et erasme et qu'après elle a été changée
parce que les colombes de sécurité ils
étaient les plus frais confortables que
quelques années
remplacé par une nouvelle vie moderne je
suis quand même un peu dommage parce que
qu'ils font quand même un potentiel
et puis il y aurait peut-être steen et
sa créativité pour lui donner une
deuxième vie et puis eux l'année par de
nouveaux horizons alors prenez deuxième
bien l'objet central bis à son histoire
et puis faudrait qu'on la situation
pourquoi cet objet utile des faits les
déduit qu'on avait inventé cette et à
vivre pour créer des crédits les
villages et les gares la plaine la
montagne
krainer lien entre les longues secondes
alors pour créer des liens un bon
endroit
tout simplement outre une nourriture du
corps google changement brutal
alors je lui la saucisse d'idées le tarn
et de de l'instruction avec la terrine
pour en faire une terrasse à propos de
terrasses que la cabine
malgré elle elle me ferai les peuples
impossibilité de faire avec un poids
favorable parasols et ses fenêtres
l'entrecôte lumière où on va on va les
ont vu leur contrat maximum d'air quand
on a commencé à réfléchir à
l'aménagement de l'espace
à l'époque dans son ancienne vie à
décaper les gens les terres de boules
rentes et emil janak fera réfléchir plus
soit assise alors je propose de faire un
bon coup à faire tout bord de la cabine
le tag mieux ils ont pu reprendre et
sortir et un accès pour le barman alors
saisi du site convivial des robes noires
marquées
dans ce marais là dedans et puis le
descendre ce ben moubamba sa cellule
si la bête est actuellement dans la
cabine alors on va reprendre la
typologie les ondes de bois l'amiable
travail est on va prendre tout simple et
tout en lien avec le passé pour
concentre entre saint michel 10 et sa
nouvelle ligne une sorte de correction
puis on va faire la même chose
ac dc et l'ambiance se dire que on va
garder le lait bandé consuming de le
prie aime la peinture qui craquèle les
bosses les rayons on va garder tout ça
quand vous de contrainte voire à verdon
avec des amis ou sentiers et des gens
oublient durable alors continuons à
réfléchir
je suis atterré les gens qui se
déplacent à la clavier pourquoi parfois
contraires sur la cabine qui se déplace
vers les jantes lui redonner sa mobilité
à l'époque les plus mobiles et sur un
câble lui donner une belle solidité pour
qu'elle aille à la région confère un
barreau millions par imaginer que notre
marché
un hongrois quiz est advenu clairière
mais cette cabine s'est posé un peu sur
la ligne
la leçon que vient un trajet son câble
car la paix est donc et puis elle va
vous s'accrochèrent 20 triaire voyez un
compartiment où il ya des chaises d'apia
légumes oubliés
installée il ya barman l'atelier soit
son frère c'est bien et puis alors sa
vidéo c'est que vous vous déplacerez la
cabine ou qui font comme ils seront
nombreux un peu du clic et cuire les
promeneurs seront au programme tout cet
abîme et puis alors finalement la table
comme dans sa fonction première
il crée alors ce que je veux faire
passer à travers ces idées nous le dise
ah comme c'est déjà de montrer qu'on est
très bien partie du vide rien deviner en
entre un objet en inspirons 4 passes et
on essayait du crédit de mâchoire et
puis si c'est apporter tout le monde
essayait de voir un objet dur que je
vois dans ce sens mais si le regarder
comme ça peut-être et décidé de veiller
à la prochaine fois que vous allez jeter
un bon j'ai fait le test cet exercice et
pied si elle doit ou détournés comme
libération
et puis s'il vous plaît bien vu que deux
bretelles